y
[Música]
cada vez con más frecuencia escuchamos
en los medios de comunicación
información acerca del cambio climático
pero lo que pocas veces nos dicen es que
el cambio climático es el colapso del
modelo económico que sostiene a la
humanidad el cambio climático no es una
crisis ambiental es una crisis humana y
es una de las mayores crisis a las que
nuestra civilización se ha visto
enfrentada esa crisis es causada por un
modelo económico basado en la extracción
indolente de la naturaleza y la
explotación de muchos seres humanos la
ciencia nos ha demostrado cada vez con
evidencia más contundente de que las
actividades antrópicas han cambiado la
composición química de la atmósfera ha
cambiado tanto a niveles que no vemos
hace dos millones de años cuando el homo
sapiens habitaba la faz de la tierra o
sea somos los primeros seres humanos que
respiramos aire con las condiciones que
estamos respirando en este momento eso
ha generado un calentamiento del planeta
un aumento del orden de un grado
centígrado de temperatura respecto a
niveles preindustriales que es el
momento cero de esta historia cuando el
ser humano tuvo acceso a los pozos
petroleros hace más o menos dos siglos
en adelante ha ocurrido es que hemos
tenido entonces derretimiento de las
capas de hielo casquetes polares
glaciares y eso aumentaba el nivel del
mar en todo el planeta poblaciones
insulares por ejemplo como providencia o
como muchos otros países e islas que
están en este momento entre graves
riesgos por aumento en el nivel del mar
y que se deben ante el riesgo cada vez
más latente de verse sumergidas en las
profundidades del océano con los
aumentos de temperatura también hemos
cambiado el ciclo hidrológico cada vez
es más frecuente que ocurran incendios
forestales por ejemplo lo que pasó este
año 2020 empezamos con incendios
forestales en australia después tuvimos
a siberia a pleno círculo polar ártico
con temperaturas por encima de 35 grados
centígrados por lo largo de varias
semanas eso liberó tanto gas de efecto
invernadero como lo que libera el españa
en un solo año vimos también el
amazonas' arder
hemos visto incendios forestales a lo
largo de todo el planeta las olas de
calor las sequías pero por otro lado
también las tormentas las inundaciones
recordemos el huracán no está
apenas pocos días que deja san andrés y
providencia en una crisis humanitaria
son las poblaciones más vulnerables las
que están viendo las peores
consecuencias del cambio climático el
cambio climático no es un futuro
distópico no es un futuro apocalíptico
es la realidad que tenemos pero podemos
cambiarla es por eso que desde las
naciones unidas- se ha planteado el
acuerdo de parís este acuerdo de parís
lo que busca es que las temperaturas del
planeta no aumenten por encima de dos
grados centígrados respecto a niveles
preindustriales en la media de lo
posible que esas temperaturas no
aumenten por encima de un grado y medio
si seguimos como vamos a esas
temperaturas van a llegar a cuatro
grados centígrados para finales de siglo
si los distintos países del mundo
cumplen lo que hasta el momento se han
comprometido a hacer en el acuerdo de
parís esas temperaturas pueden llegar a
tres grados centígrados conclusión
estamos muy lejos del punto al que
queremos llegar y ese punto al que
queremos llegar no es un punto que es
arbitrario cada día las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero aumentan más
que puede pasar si aumentamos
temperaturas por encima de los grados
centígrados
colapso de muchos ecosistemas
la ciencia nos habla de la sexta
extinción de la pérdida de un millón de
especies a nivel planetario tenemos la
certificación son las que se nos están
haciendo más áridas y son zonas que
actualmente son áridas para poner un
ejemplo el norte de áfrica o siria un
país expuesto a un conflicto geopolítico
desde hace muchos años donde las
personas han tenido que emigrar a otras
regiones también sabemos que está
terminándose la vegetación que tenemos
perdidas de ecosistemas que tenemos
incendios forestales que ocurren por
todo el planeta finalmente lo que está
ocurriendo es que estamos poniendo en
jaque la seguridad alimentaria del
planeta el asunto es que se deja que
puede ser jaque mate para muchas
poblaciones son las poblaciones más
vulnerables las que están viéndose
afectadas por este fenómeno pero en la
medida en la que aumentan las
temperaturas no van a ser solo las
poblaciones más vulnerables vamos a
hacer tú voy a hacer yo vamos a estar
expuestos a olas de calor vamos a estar
expuestos a estrés cívico por falta de
agua pero también por exceso de agua a
fallas en la producción energética a
colapsos en la producción de alimentos a
degradación de hábitat finalmente lo que
está ocurriendo es
en colapso nuestra existencia el planeta
tierra va a seguir girando alrededor del
sol y habrá otras especies y encontrará
una manera de equilibrarse es la especie
humana la que está particularmente en
peligro cuando pensamos las distintas
elementos que han conjurado esta crisis
vemos que la alimentación está en el
centro de ella somos más de siete mil
millones de personas que nos tenemos que
alimentar lo que es irónico y triste en
medio de todo esto es que ese duplicar
la producción de alimentos a nivel
global no ha significado que todos los
seres humanos tengamos de manera
igualitaria y justa acceso al alimento
todavía y sigue habiendo hambruna
todavía seguimos teniendo poblaciones
que mueren de hambre es por eso que la
alimentación se nos vuelve un punto
central un punto central del problema
pero también un punto central de la
solución la ciencia nos muestra que si
no cambiamos la manera en la que nos
alimentamos los 7.000 millones de
habitantes que habitamos el planeta y si
no cambiamos el sistema productivo de
alimentos de manera radical no vamos a
poder cumplir con lo que tenemos pactado
en el acuerdo de parís y ese número no
es solamente un número
y finalmente en la existencia de la
especie humana la que está en riesgo en
la manera en la que la conocemos en este
momento el suelo que tenemos actualmente
tiene las condiciones suficientes para
sostener estos 7.000 millones de
habitantes pero con condiciones
distintas necesitamos una transición
distinta a partir de la alimentación
podemos pensar y elegir qué comemos ese
es un acto personal ese es un acto
individual no necesitamos que los demás
nos digan que debemos comer muchos
estudios nos muestran que el consumo
intensivo de carne sobre todo carne de
ganado es parte del problema porque no
pensamos en reducir esos consumos porque
no pensamos en abrir la nevera por
ejemplo y ver qué es lo que hay ahí como
llegó ese producto a mi nevera cómo
llego a mi mesa cuáles son las emisiones
asociadas a eso solo nos podemos
informar eso es otro punto fundamental
necesitamos vencer lo que lo que
típicamente los medios de comunicación y
las redes sociales nos muestran hay
mucha información información confiable
a la que podemos acceder y tenemos que
hacerlo es parte de nuestra obligación
tenemos que pensar entonces en que las
soluciones al cambio climático
son colectiva sin lugar a dudas pero lo
colectivo ha fallado la voluntad
política ha fallado pero la voluntad
individual también puede ser
transformadora necesitamos distintas
áreas del conocimiento para resolver el
cambio climático no debemos depender de
un único héroe de hollywood como nos han
mostrado en las películas que solo con
su conocimiento nos puede salvar todos
podemos ser héroes y heroínas que
aportamos a esta solución las saberes
científicos como los conocemos pero
también los saberes originarios también
los saberes populares personas que
conocen su territorio que no han perdido
su vínculo con el territorio como la
mayoría de habitantes que estamos
asentados en regiones citadinas tenemos
que pensar en ese diálogo de saberes a
partir de muchísimas estrategias
necesitamos empatía restaurar esos lazos
de solidaridad con de los demás seres
humanos esta crisis esta emergencia
climática es la traducción a una de las
tantas traducciones en el sistema físico
de esa falta de empatía necesitamos
también pensar en nuestros actos
individuales y por tanto necesitamos
pensar por ejemplo en algo tan sencillo
como que voy a comer hoy
sabemos quiénes podemos tomar esa
decisión hay muchos otros que no pueden
tomar esa decisión porque han sido
abandonados por este sistema
pensemos desde lo que nosotros podemos
hacer y generemos un cambio esto es
transformador esto es colectivo pero lo
individual también puede aportar vos y
yo somos parte de esa historia y vos y
yo podemos aportar las soluciones para
el cambio climático
[Música]